I didn't see this one happen. But Ben, one of the producer here at This American Life , he saw it. He was in the news room here at our home station, WBEZ Chicago, one day, when Dan Blumberg arrived for work.
我没亲眼见过这个。但我们这儿的制作人之一本（Ben）见过。有一天，他在我们电台总部——芝加哥WBEZ——工作时，丹·布鲁姆伯格（Dan Blumberg）来上班了。
And Dan walks in. And he's just swollen, like everywhere. Like, his eyes-- here, I'll do the face. It was like--
丹走进来时，整个人都肿了。就像……到处都肿了。他的眼睛——等等，我给你表演一下那个表情。就像是……
Oh, wow. You're puffing out your cheeks and squinting your eyes.
噢，天哪。你在嘟起脸颊，眯着眼睛。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, his ears were like cauliflower. I was like, Dan, are you OK? And he says, "It's OK. Last night, I ate some crab." And everybody's reaction is, of course, oh, you're allergic! You need to go to the hospital! And he's like, no, no, no. This happens pretty regularly because I love crab. And I'm allergic, but it only happens one out of every three times.
对，对，对。我是说，他的耳朵像花椰菜一样。我问他：“丹，你没事吧？”他说：“没事，昨晚我吃了一点螃蟹。”大家的反应当然是：“噢，你过敏了！你得去医院！”而他却说：“不，不，不。这经常发生，因为我太爱吃螃蟹了。虽然我过敏，但每吃三次才会有一次反应。”
What?
什么？
Yeah. It was a calculated risk. One out of every three times, he would turn into, like, the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man. Yeah, so, I mean I suppose this is the part where you'd bring Dan in.
是啊。这是一种经过计算的风险。每吃三次螃蟹，他就得变成像“棉花糖人”那样。所以，我想这该是你请丹上场的时候了。
I should have called in sick that day.
那天我本该请病假的。
This, of course, is Dan.
当然，这就是丹。
I think that morning it was mostly the eyes that would have been kind of freaking people out, very heavy eyelids, kind of probably a sunken look to them.
我想那天早上，主要是他的眼睛会把人吓坏，眼皮非常沉重，看起来可能有点凹陷。
Dan did confirm everything that Ben said and more. He's been allergic to crab and lobster since he was a kid. The night before this incident, he had eaten crab. And he got the worst reaction he'd had in years. It was a wake up call. Not that he going to stop eating crab and lobster-- no, no. He was going to keep doing that. But now, he'd do it--
丹证实了本所说的一切，甚至更多。他从小就对螃蟹和龙虾过敏。事件发生的前一天晚上，他吃了螃蟹，结果出现了多年来最严重的一次反应。这给他敲响了警钟。但这并不意味着他会停止吃螃蟹和龙虾——不，不。他还是会继续吃。但现在，他会……
Only if I have Benadryl as a sort of aperitif. And only if I have an inhaler just in case it were to spread to my lungs. And I have an EpiPen.
只有在我把苯海拉明（Benadryl）当作餐前酒的情况下才会吃。而且必须随身带着吸入器，以防万一过敏反应扩散到肺部。我还准备了一支肾上腺素笔（EpiPen）。
An EpiPen, if you've never heard of it, is the injection that you stab yourself with in an emergency if you get a life threatening allergic reaction. And this is his system. And he says it's working for him. And no, his doctor does not know. He risks this twice a year or so. He says his wife's not so crazy about it, partly because the Benadryl makes him really sleepy.
如果你从没听说过肾上腺素笔，它是一种注射器，如果你出现危及生命的过敏反应，就在紧急情况下扎自己一下。这就是他的“系统”。他说这对他很有效。而且，不，他的医生并不知道。他每年大约会冒两次这样的险。他说他妻子不太喜欢这样，部分原因是苯海拉明会让他非常困倦。
But the poisoning myself, it's not that bad. Like I said, I get sleepy from the Benadryl. That's the worst part, I get really tired.
但毒害自己其实也没那么糟糕。就像我说的，苯海拉明会让我犯困。那是唯一糟糕的部分，我感到非常疲惫。
But if you find yourself saying the sentence, the poisoning myself is not that bad--
但如果你发现自己说出“毒害自己其实也没那么糟糕”这样的话……
Yeah, I mean, I think there's something probably to that. You know, I like it. What can I say?
是的，我想这可能确实说明了什么。你知道，我就是喜欢它。我能说什么呢？
This whole thing made me think of some book that you would read about the decline of the Roman Empire, people eating so much that they would have to throw up so they could eat some more. This is like someday, people are going to write, what was America like back in its heyday? Well, what it was like was people with severe allergies would eat the thing that they are allergic to but just have meds at the ready to stab themselves with and cure themselves.
整件事让我想起了一些关于罗马帝国衰落的书，人们吃得太多，不得不催吐以便能吃得更多。这就像有朝一日，人们会写道：美国的全盛时期是什么样的？嗯，那时候的情况就是：严重过敏的人会吃掉他们过敏的东西，但随时准备好药物扎自己一下来治疗。
But, you know, reaching out to friends, and family, and to strangers over the internet this past two weeks, I have learned that what Dan did is actually not that uncommon.
不过，过去两周我联系了朋友、家人和互联网上的陌生人，我了解到丹的做法其实并不罕见。
I do have willpower. But when it comes to the whole pizza thing, I don't hesitate. I just go ahead and eat it.
我有自制力，但一提到披萨，我就毫不犹豫。我直接就吃了。
Ruthie Zinchuck in Charlotte, North Carolina, is lactose intolerant. She can't digest milk, or cheese, or any dairy product, which is a problem because as a transplanted Jersey girl, she says, she likes her pizza.
北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的露西·金查克（Ruthie Zinchuck）患有乳糖不耐症。她无法消化牛奶、奶酪或任何乳制品，这很麻烦，因为作为一个从新泽西搬来的女孩，她说，她喜欢吃披萨。
Well, we do have Pizza Hut. Out of nowhere, I'll get severe stomach cramping. And I'll have to go to the bathroom like immediately. It's no joke.
好吧，我们有必胜客。冷不丁地，我就会出现严重的胃痉挛。我得立刻去洗手间。这不是开玩笑的。
And so how often do you have pizza now?
那你现在多久吃一次披萨？
I would say at least a couple times a week.
我想至少一周几次。
Oh, a couple times a week?
噢，一周几次？
Yeah. It's always our go-to when we don't know what to eat. My fiancee and I are like, well, I guess pizza will work. And he'll always just look at me and say, "Really? Are you sure?"
对。当我们不知道吃什么的时候，这总是我们的首选。我和未婚夫会说，好吧，我想披萨就行。他总是看着我说：“真的吗？你确定？”
In Cleveland, Ohio, Elise Hagisfeld, and her older sister, and her younger sister, and her mom, and her daughter are all allergic to tomatoes, citrus, pineapple, strawberries in various combinations. Elise herself gets hives. It makes her face blotchy. She gets itchy. But they all continue to eat this stuff.
在俄亥俄州克利夫兰，伊丽丝·哈吉斯菲尔德（Elise Hagisfeld），还有她的姐姐、妹妹、妈妈和女儿，都对西红柿、柑橘、菠萝、草莓的不同组合过敏。伊丽丝本人会起荨麻疹，脸上起红斑，浑身发痒。但她们都继续吃这些东西。
I don't know if I have any great stories about it because we just do it all the time. We apparently are a family that has absolutely no self-control or good sense. I'm not sure which, but whatever. I like it!
我不知道关于这个我有什么精彩的故事，因为我们总是这样。显然我们这个家庭完全没有自制力，或者说缺乏常识。我不知道是哪种，但无所谓。我喜欢！
Which is, of course, pretty much what Dan said, and what my senior producer's mother-in-law told me, too. Her name is Barbara Melman, and I reached her on vacation. She said that a couple years ago, after some abdominal surgery, she had a few episodes where she got incredibly sick, throwing up, rushing to the emergency room, getting an IV, an anti-nausea medication, until she realized that each time this happened, she'd eaten popcorn, or nuts, or trail mix before. And so she cut those from her diet. But over time, she has snuck that stuff back in.
这当然和丹说的差不多，也是我高级制作人的岳母告诉我的。她叫芭芭拉·梅尔曼（Barbara Melman），我是在她度假时联系到她的。她说几年前，做过腹部手术后，她有几次病得非常严重，呕吐，被送进急诊室，输液，服用止吐药，直到她意识到每次发生这种情况前，她都吃过爆米花、坚果或什锦杂果。于是她从饮食中去掉了这些东西，但随着时间推移，她又偷偷地把它们加了回来。
And being on vacation now, I've got a room full of popcorn and trail mix.
现在度假的时候，我的房间里全都是爆米花和什锦杂果。
You do? Right now?
你有吗？现在？
I do. I'm staring at it as we're speaking, mm-hm.
我有。我们说话的时候我正盯着它们看，嗯。
Wait, don't you think you're playing with fire?
等等，你不觉得你在玩火吗？
Well, you know, it's not going to kill me. And if it does, I guess I won't know. It won't kill me. No, I mean, it's throwing up. It's not like I have to go through surgery.
嗯，你知道，它不会杀了我。如果真的杀了，我想我也不会知道。它杀不了我。不，我是说，这只是呕吐。又不像是得做手术。
Just a quick trip to the hospital, an IV, some medication.
只是去趟急诊室，输个液，吃点药。
A few hours, mm-hm. And meet some nice people and leave.
几个小时而已，嗯。还能认识些不错的人，然后离开。
The ER is a virtual laboratory of dysfunctional behaviors and bad choices.
急诊室就是一个功能障碍行为和错误选择的虚拟实验室。
Do you just feel like, as a doctor, what is wrong with people?
作为医生，你是否会觉得人们到底是怎么了？
Oh, every day, every day.
噢，每天，每天都是这样。
This is Michelle DeVito, an emergency room doctor at an urban hospital in Washington, D.C. And she says that nearly every day, she sees somebody with a food allergy who has eaten the food that they're not supposed and ended up in her ER.
这是米歇尔·德维托（Michelle DeVito），华盛顿特区一家城市医院的急诊医生。她说几乎每天都能看到有人因为食物过敏而吃了不该吃的东西，最后被送进她的急诊室。
It's such a thing that it's not up for debate.
这已经是一种普遍现象，没什么好辩论的。
Dr. DeVito told me story after story there are the people with esophageal problems who are not supposed to eat steak who come in again and again. The same people with steak caught in their throats, looking guilty, avoiding eye contact with her, requiring a gastroenterologist to be called in for an emergency endoscopy.
德维托医生给我讲了一个又一个故事：有些食道有问题的人不该吃牛排，却一次又一次地来。同样的人，牛排卡在喉咙里，一脸愧疚，不敢和她对视，还得叫胃肠科医生来做紧急内窥镜检查。
How much of what you see in an ER is people who are their own worst enemies?
你在急诊室看到的情况中，有多少是属于“自讨苦吃”的？
Oh, I think maybe half. I think that the smokers, the out-of-control diabetics, the people who get in a car accident from text messaging on the phone-- I think so much of the pathology we see in the ER is a result of bad choices. And some of them, decades of bad choices.
噢，我想大概一半吧。我想吸烟者、失控的糖尿病患者、因为发短信出车祸的人……我认为我们在急诊室看到的很多病理结果都是错误选择的结果。其中一些甚至是几十年的错误选择。
I think there once we've become adults, most of us are aware of the different ways in which we can be our own worst enemies, not just with what we eat and with our health, but in how we deal with people, how we handle certain situations. Well, in this hour, prepare to meet people who make my problems and yours when it comes to this seem like nothing. We have people who create problems for themselves in spectacular, life-changing ways that they do not know how to stop. We have one man who finds himself suddenly unable to do his job, others who are sabotaging relationships, and they cannot themselves when they do it. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Stay with us.
我认为一旦我们成为了成年人，我们大多数人都意识到了自己成为自身最大敌人的不同方式，不仅是在饮食和健康方面，还有在处理人际关系和特定情况的方式上。在这个小时里，准备好见见那些让你的问题显得微不足道的人吧。有些人以惊人的、改变生活的方式给自己制造麻烦，却不知道如何停止。有一个人突然无法胜任自己的工作，其他人则在破坏关系，当他们这样做时，自己也控制不了。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。请继续收听。
Act One, Aces are Wild. Ken Fueson is a baseball fan and a lifelong supporter of the St. Louis Cardinals. And he had the same experience that a lot of Cardinal fans had back on October 3, 2000, watching his team play the Atlanta Braves. It was the first game of the National League playoffs.
第一幕，王牌疯狂（Aces are Wild）。肯·福森（Ken Fueson）是一位棒球迷，也是圣路易斯红雀队的终身支持者。2000年10月3日那天，他和许多红雀队球迷有了同样的经历，当时他在看红雀队对阵亚特兰大勇士队。那是国家联盟季后赛的第一场比赛。
I remember exactly where I was. I was at Johnny's Hall of Fame, which is a sports bar in Des Moines. I was sitting at a table. I had a big glass of iced tea and a patty melt sandwich. The Cardinals scored six runs in the first inning. This is going to be fantastic.
我记得我当时确切的位置。我在得梅因的一家运动酒吧“约翰尼名人堂”（Johnny's Hall of Fame）。我坐在一张桌子旁。手里有一大杯冰茶和一份肉饼三明治。红雀队在第一局就得了六分。我想，这太棒了。
The starting pitcher for the Cardinals in this game was Rick Ankiel, a young phenom who'd had a great rookie season. He pitched two innings, no problem. But in the third, he lost control.
红雀队在这场比赛中的先发投手是里克·安基尔（Rick Ankiel），一位在菜鸟赛季表现出色的年轻天才。他投了两局，没问题。但在第三局，他失控了。
I don't know where the first wild pitch went, but it was like-- you thought to yourself, you know, it's slipped out of his hands. It's like one of those scenes that they show, like the pitcher stumbling and the ball goes up in the air. And then it happened again. You're still kind of thinking, OK, maybe the nervousness of the moment, or whatever. But you're not thinking, this is going to be a big problem. He's going to settle down. And then, it keeps happening.
我不知道第一个狂投（wild pitch）飞向了哪里，但就像是……你当时想，他一定是手滑了。就像电影里那种投手踉跄、球飞向空中的场景。然后它又发生了。你还是觉得，好吧，也许是那一刻的紧张，或者其他什么。但你没想过这是一个大问题，你会觉得他会冷静下来的。然后，它就一直发生。
I'm thinking, there has to be some sort of physical explanation for this. You know, there's something wrong with his arm. This isn't even little league quality wild pitches. It's beyond that. I mean, it's like you would have to try to throw it this badly. And I'm at this bar, and people are laughing at him.
我在想，一定有什么生理上的解释。你知道，他的手臂一定出问题了。这甚至不像是小联盟水平的狂投。这更严重。我是说，就像你必须努力才能投得这么烂一样。我待在酒吧里，人们都在嘲笑他。
Ankiel gets pulled from the game. Cardinals win. And in the next round of playoffs, they're up against the New York Mets.
安基尔被换下场。红雀队赢了。在下一轮季后赛中，他们对阵纽约大都会队。
And so they bring Ankiel out to try again for the second game of the series. He lasts 2/3rds of an inning. He doesn't even get out the first inning-- throws two wild pitches, walks three. It's literally like watching your kid in a peewee game.
于是他们让安基尔在系列赛的第二场比赛中再次尝试。他只撑了2/3局。他甚至没能投完第一局——投了两个狂投，保送了三次。这简直就像在看你孩子打少儿比赛一样。
Wild pitch. He's got guys in the third row ducking. Friendlies ducking back there. Bob, you all right down there? You ducking? You feel like you're safe behind that screen?
狂投。第三排的人都在躲闪。后排的朋友也在躲。鲍勃，你没事吧？你在躲吗？你觉得在那块挡网后面安全吗？
And as a fan, you're just, this can't be happening. It's disbelief. I don't believe this. Then, you get angry at him. What's he trying to do out there? What's going on? And then, you start feeling sorry for him.
作为一个球迷，你只是觉得，这不可能发生。是难以置信。我不相信。然后，你会对他感到生气。他在外面试图干什么？发生了什么？然后，你开始同情他。
And this is borderline ridiculous.
这简直荒谬透顶。
On a human level-- that's the other horrible part of this-- he's naked in front of the world. He's out there trying to get this back. And it ain't coming back. You feel horrible for him, yeah.
从人的层面来看——这是最可怕的部分——他在全世界面前赤身裸体。他在外面努力想找回状态。但状态就是回不来了。你真的为他感到难过，是的。
Ankiel's bad streak eventually got him sent down to the minor leagues. He stopped pitching, came back to the major leagues as an outfielder. But watching Ankiel that day in the bar made Ken think of a different player from years before, Steve Blass. He played for Pittsburgh. His name has become shorthand for any pitcher who suddenly becomes his own worst enemy and loses the ability to throw the ball. They call it Steve Blass Disease. Blass was an all-star, on the cover of Sports Illustrated . Older fans remember him winning game seven of the 1971 World Series for the Pirates. After the Series, he had a great season in '72, won 19 games.
安基尔糟糕的表现最终导致他被下放到小联盟。他停止了投球，后来作为外野手回到了大联盟。但那天在酒吧里看着安基尔，让肯想起了几年前的另一位球员，史蒂夫·布拉斯（Steve Blass）。他曾为匹兹堡海盗队效力。他的名字已经成为所有突然成为自身最大敌人、丧失投球能力的投手的代名词。他们称之为“史蒂夫·布拉斯症候群”。布拉斯曾经入选全明星赛，还上过《体育画报》封面。老球迷记得他在1971年世界大赛第七场为海盗队获胜。系列赛结束后，他在72年表现出色，赢了19场比赛。
And then, in 1973, for no apparent reason, no physical injury of any kind, he stopped being able to throw strikes. He never recovered, and ended his career. He was a player falling apart for purely psychological reasons, which can happen to any athlete in any sport, of course. But the suddenness of Blass' fall and the visibility of his fall-- he was one of the leading pitchers in baseball, and he just lost it-- it got people's attention. And if you want to understand what Steve Blass Disease is about, one place you can go is Steve Blass.
然后，在1973年，没有明显的原因，没有任何身体伤害，他突然无法投出好球了。他从未恢复，结束了自己的职业生涯。他是一位纯粹因为心理原因而崩溃的球员，当然，这在任何运动中的任何运动员身上都可能发生。但布拉斯崩溃的突然性和可见性——他是棒球界顶尖投手之一，却突然失控了——这引起了人们的注意。如果你想了解什么是“史蒂夫·布拉斯症候群”，你可以去问史蒂夫·布拉斯本人。
So I'm sitting in my living room with my wife. We're watching the playoffs with the Cardinals. And Rick Ankiel starts throwing the ball all over the place-- behind people, to the backstop.
所以我正和妻子坐在客厅里。我们正在看红雀队的季后赛。里克·安基尔开始把球扔得到处都是——扔向人群后面，扔向护网。
Turns out Steve Blass was watching that same Cardinals game that Ken Fueson saw.
事实证明，史蒂夫·布拉斯也在看肯·福森看到的同一场红雀队的比赛。
And I turned to my wife, Karen, and I said, "Karen, I'm predicting within the next five minutes, the phone will ring." Well, three minutes later, it rang. And I picked it up and said, "Hi, Paul." My good friend, Paul Meyer, beat writer for the Pirates who was covering the playoffs for the Pittsburgh Post-Gazette . He said, "How do you know it's me?" I said, "Well, of course it's you. Somebody just went off the planet again."
我对妻子卡伦（Karen）说：“卡伦，我敢预测接下来的五分钟内，电话会响。”嗯，三分钟后，电话响了。我拿起电话说：“嘿，保罗。”我的好朋友保罗·迈耶（Paul Meyer），海盗队的随队记者，正在为《匹兹堡邮报》报道季后赛。他说：“你怎么知道是我？”我说：“嗯，当然是你。又有人从地球上掉下去了。”
How many interviews have you given about this over the years, do you think?
这些年来你大概接受过多少次关于这个话题的采访？
I have an 800 number.
我有专门的800号码。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I mean, whenever anybody-- when Rick Ankiel imploded in the playoffs, when Mark Wohlers was doing his thing, Steve Sax, Chuck Knoblauch And I know why there's interest. I understand. I understand that. People are making a living. It's a curious subject. It's a fascinating subject to go from 19 wins, to three, to none, and then out. So I've had a great deal of patience with it.
我是说，每当有谁……当里克·安基尔在季后赛崩溃时，当马克·沃尔斯（Mark Wohlers）遇到麻烦时，史蒂夫·萨克斯（Steve Sax），查克·诺布劳奇（Chuck Knoblauch）……我知道为什么人们感兴趣。我理解。我明白。人们也要以此谋生。这是一个好奇的话题。从19胜，到3胜，到无胜，然后出局，这是一个引人入胜的话题。所以我对此一直很有耐心。
Steve Blass turns 70 this coming Wednesday. And next month, he's publishing an autobiography called A Pirate for Life . The title refers to his 10 years as a player, and to the nearly three decades after that that he served as a Pirates color commentator on the air. He says that he wrote the book to tell the story that you can come back from the kind of public collapse that he suffered.
史蒂夫·布拉斯下周三就要70岁了。下个月，他将出版一本自传，书名叫《海盗一生》（A Pirate for Life）。书名指的是他作为球员的10年，以及此后近三十年作为海盗队评论员的时光。他说他写这本书是为了告诉大家，你可以从他遭受的那种公开崩溃中走出来。
In the immediate aftermath, he got a job selling school rings. He said he drank too much. He says it was hard to go out to the grocery store and be recognized by people. The book covers, but does not dwell on, how his pitching career came apart, which he calls "the abyss." He says he can't name exactly when his problem began, what game it was. He remembers it as just a gradual slide.
在接下来的日子里，他找到了一份卖校友戒指的工作。他说他喝得太多了。他说很难出门去杂货店，因为会被人认出来。书里提到了他的投球生涯是如何崩溃的——他称之为“深渊”，但并没有过度纠结。他说他无法说出问题是从什么时候开始的，是哪场比赛。他记得那只是一个渐进的下滑。
There was not one specific issue, item, time, at bat, game. And to this day, I don't know why. I don't know what caused that. There's still frustration in me because I never had a sore arm, and I had the perfect body. You know, I wasn't heavy or anything. But I still don't know exactly what caused it.
没有一个具体的问题、事项、时间点、击球或比赛。直到今天，我仍然不知道为什么。我不知道是什么导致了这一切。我心里依然有挫败感，因为我从来没有受过伤，而且我有完美的体格。你知道，我并不胖什么的。但我仍然不知道到底是什么导致的。
I've been going back and reading. And I saw Roger Angell wrote a piece years ago for The New Yorker .
我回去读了一些东西。我看到罗杰·安吉尔（Roger Angell）多年前为《纽约客》写过一篇文章。
Wonderful piece.
非常棒的文章。
Yeah, a really beautiful story. And he tries to figure out, well, what game was it? And he names an April, 1973, game with the Cubs that you pitched. And then he says, maybe it's that game. And then, there's another game on June 11 with the Braves in Atlanta. And I was wondering, do you even remember either of those games? Like, do those games stand out as significant?
是的，一个非常优美的故事。他试图搞清楚，嗯，那到底是哪场比赛？他指出了你投的一场1973年4月对阵小熊队的比赛。然后他说，也许是那场。然后，6月11日还有一场对阵亚特兰大勇士队的比赛。我想知道，你甚至还记得那两场比赛吗？就像，那两场比赛作为关键点脱颖而出吗？
Um, I don't remember the Cubs game. if he's referring to the game where I came in relief in Atlanta, which I think was the case, I remember it more than any other game I've pitched in my life because it was just-- it was the absolute bottom of the pit. And I remember after that game, we flew to Cincinnati. And I didn't even go to my hotel room. I just walked the streets of Cincinnati until dawn. And it was just one of the awfulest games and awfulest nights that I've ever had in my life.
嗯，我不记得小熊队那场比赛。如果他指的是我在亚特兰大那场担任中继投手的比赛，我想应该是那场，比起我一生中投过的任何比赛，我记得那场更多，因为那简直是……那是深渊的最底部。我记得那场比赛后，我们飞往辛辛那提。我甚至没回酒店房间。我就在辛辛那提的街头一直走到天亮。那是我一生中最糟糕的比赛，最糟糕的夜晚之一。
And so what do you remember of the experience of being on the mound during that game? Like, did it occur to you when you were on the mound, OK, something different is happening now that I haven't experienced before?
那你对那场比赛在投手丘上的经历有什么记忆？就像，当你在投手丘上时，你是否意识到，好吧，现在发生了某种我以前从未经历过的不同寻常的事情？
Yes. That game in Atlanta, I said, there is something tragically wrong here. And I am lost out here. I don't have a clue of what I'm doing. I start to wind up, and I just kind of almost freeze. And there's no flow, there's no rhythm. I knew I shouldn't be out there. But I didn't want to quit. I wanted to keep trying to find it.
是的。在那场亚特兰大的比赛中，我说，这里发生了极其严重的问题。我在这里迷失了。我根本不知道我在做什么。我开始投球姿势，然后我就几乎僵住了。没有流畅感，没有节奏感。我知道我不该在那里。但我不想放弃。我想继续寻找它。
Roger Angell's account of that game-- I mean, I'm not even sure if I should read this or not.
罗杰·安吉尔对那场比赛的描述……我是说，我甚至不确定我该不该读这个。
Oh, I know it by heart.
噢，我倒背如流。
Yeah-- oh, really? All right. Just for listeners, then, so you get called in in the fifth inning. And the Pirates are trailing already. So you're coming into a losing game. They're trailing by 8 to 3, and Roger Angell writes, "Blass walked the first two men he faced. Gave up a stolen base, and a wild pitch, and run-scoring single before retiring the side. In the sixth, Blass walked Darrell Evans. He walked Mike Lum, throwing one pitch behind him in the process, which allowed Evans to move down to second. Dusty Baker singled, driving in a run. Ralph Garr grounded out. Davey Johnson singled, scoring another run. Marty Perez walked. Pitcher Ron Reed singled, driving in two more runs, and was wild pitched to second. Johnny Oates walked. Frank Tepedino singled, driving in two runs. And Steve Blass was finally relieved."
是吗……噢，真的吗？好吧。那为了听众，当时你在第五局被叫上场。海盗队已经落后了。所以你进的是一场正在输的比赛。他们以3比8落后，罗杰·安吉尔写道：“布拉斯保送了面对的前两名打者。丢掉了一个盗垒，一个狂投，还有一个得分安打，才结束了那一局。在第六局，布拉斯保送了达雷尔·埃文斯（Darrell Evans）。他保送了迈克·卢姆（Mike Lum），在这个过程中甚至投了一个球在他身后，这让埃文斯推进到了二垒。达斯蒂·贝克（Dusty Baker）打出一支安打，得了一分。拉尔夫·加尔（Ralph Garr）打出地滚球出局。戴维·约翰逊（Davey Johnson）打出安打，再得一分。马蒂·佩雷斯（Marty Perez）获得保送。投手罗恩·里德（Ron Reed）打出安打，再得两分，并因狂投推进到二垒。约翰尼·奥茨（Johnny Oates）获得保送。弗兰克·特佩迪诺（Frank Tepedino）打出安打，再得两分。史蒂夫·布拉斯终于被换下场。”
Yeah, yeah. It was awful. It was just-- it was a nightmare. But I've been taught, and developed, and I firmly believe you don't quit. I just wasn't wired that way. And I wanted to be convinced. If it wasn't there, I wanted to be totally convinced. And that's why I pitched all of '73, obviously. And then, all of '74, which was another nightmare in the minor leagues. And then in '75 I said, that's enough. Uncle. I've had enough.
是啊，是啊。太可怕了。那简直是一场噩梦。但我受到的教育、成长环境让我坚信你不能放弃。我的性格就是这样。而且我想让自己死心。如果状态不在了，我想彻底死心。这就是为什么我显然投完了73年整季，然后是74年，那在小联盟又是另一场噩梦。然后在75年我说，够了。我认输。我已经受够了。
I read you said to a Pittsburgh sports writer named Joe Starkey years ago, "Underneath, very privately and very personally, is a feeling I got cheated." And did you feel that it's almost like some foreign thing had taken over? Like you were hit by something that you couldn't control?
我读到多年前你对匹兹堡体育记者乔·斯塔基（Joe Starkey）说的话：“在内心深处，非常私密地，有一种被欺骗的感觉。”你是否觉得就像某种外来的东西占据了你？就像你被某种无法控制的东西击中了？
Well, I certainly had no control over it, nor did I understand it. I was just confused. I mean, I would sit up in my backyard, 3 and 4 o'clock in the morning, thinking, my god, what has happened to me? What is this? Did somebody put a curse on me or something? And I never believed that. You know, I don't believe in that junk. But it was just-- it was devastating in that I didn't know what to do about it.
嗯，我确实无法控制它，也不理解它。我只是感到困惑。我是说，我会在凌晨三四点坐在后院，心想：天哪，我到底怎么了？这是什么？是不是有人给我下了咒？我从不相信那种事。你知道，我不相信那些无稽之谈。但这确实令人崩溃，因为我不知道该怎么办。
In the decades since Steve Blass stopped pitching, researchers have been trying to figure out what to do about it and what is going on when a player falls apart like he did. And they believe that basically the problem comes down to thinking. When an elite athlete is at his or her best, when they're in the zone, their movements are automatic. They're not thinking about how their wrist turns, or their knee bends, or any of the other details.
在史蒂夫·布拉斯停止投球后的几十年里，研究人员一直在试图弄清楚该怎么做，以及当球员像他那样崩溃时到底发生了什么。他们相信问题基本上归结于“思考”。当一名精英运动员处于巅峰状态，当他们处于“状态”中时，他们的动作是自动的。他们并没有在思考手腕如何转动、膝盖如何弯曲或任何其他细节。
And when researchers bring athletes into the lab with a simulated batting cage, or a putting green, when they tell them to think about the mechanics of what they're doing, to notice where exactly the bat is moving when they're swinging, or how their elbow shifts when they're putting, the athletes-- the overwhelming majority of them-- start to choke. Thinking is the problem.
当研究人员把运动员带到模拟打击笼或推杆果岭的实验室时，当他们告诉运动员去思考动作的力学，去注意挥棒时棒子到底在向哪里移动，或者推杆时手肘如何移动时，运动员——绝大多数——开始“窒息”了。思考才是问题所在。
And interestingly, two researchers named Steven Weiss and Arthur Reber have a paper called "Curing the Dreaded Steve Blass Disease," which is going to be published in the Journal of Sports Psychology in Action . And they argue that when well-meaning coaches tell an athlete in a slump to focus more on the mechanics-- which they say is common still-- the coach can actually make things worse, not better, because he's telling a player who's already thinking too much to think even more.
有趣的是，两位研究人员斯蒂芬·韦斯（Steven Weiss）和亚瑟·雷伯（Arthur Reber）写了一篇名为《治愈可怕的史蒂夫·布拉斯症候群》的论文，即将在《运动心理学实践》杂志上发表。他们认为，当出于好意的教练告诉陷入低谷的运动员要多关注动作力学——他们说这在现在仍然很常见——教练实际上可能会让情况变得更糟，而不是更好，因为他是在让一个已经思考太多的球员思考得更多。
We have to somehow figure out a way to get you to stop thinking. You have to find some sort of mental distraction that allows them to go back to just rely upon their instincts.
我们必须想办法让你停止思考。你必须找到某种心理干扰，让他们能够回到纯粹依赖本能的状态。
This is Rick Wolff. He was a baseball player himself in the minor leagues, and he went on to counsel professional athletes whose minds were working against them. Wolff's job was to redirect them, stop them from thinking about the mechanics of what they were doing.
这是里克·沃尔夫（Rick Wolff）。他自己也曾在小联盟做过棒球运动员，后来开始辅导那些大脑与自己作对的职业运动员。沃尔夫的工作是重定向他们，让他们停止思考自己正在做的动作力学。
So if you're having problems as a pitcher throwing strikes, I need for you to stop thinking about or worrying about that. And as you wind up, I want to think about something totally different. It might be I want you to really focus on the catcher's left shin guard. I'm just trying to get them to stop thinking about where their arm angle is, and how they're delivering the ball to the plate.
所以如果你作为一个投手在投好球时遇到问题，我需要你停止去想或担心那个问题。在你做投球姿势时，我希望你思考一些完全不同的东西。可能我希望你真正专注于捕手的左护胫。我只是想让他们停止思考手臂的角度，以及他们是如何把球投向本垒板的。
And does that work?
那有效吗？
Sometimes it does. Sometimes it doesn't.
有时有效，有时无效。
It just seems like a hard thing because the more you try not to think about something, the more you're thinking about it.
这似乎很难，因为你越试图不去想某件事，你反而想得越多。
Yeah. I didn't say it was easy.
是的。我没说这很简单。
Do most of them get over it? Do most of them not get over it?
他们中大多数人能克服吗？还是大多数人不能克服？
I would say it's about 50%.
我想大概是50%。
Some of things the study says that athletes might focus on if they want to avoid thinking, they can focus on the catcher's mitt or on wherever it is that the ball is supposed to go. Golfers can focus on one word, like a general thought that describes the swing they want, like "smooth."
研究称，如果运动员想避免思考，可以专注于捕手的手套或者球应该去的任何地方。高尔夫球手可以专注于一个词，比如描述他们想要的挥杆的一般想法，比如“平滑”。
Steve Blass tried everything to get out of his abyss. He tried pitching from his knees. He tried pitching from second base. He tried pitching every night in the bullpen, and he tried to take a week off to see if the rest helped him. He watched himself on video and compared it to video of when he was pitching well. He went to a hypnotist and to a psychologist. He learned meditation and practiced it. When a friend suggested changing to looser underwear, he laughed about it with his teammates. And then, he tried it.
史蒂夫·布拉斯为了走出深渊尝试了一切。他尝试过跪着投球。他尝试过从二垒位置投球。他尝试过每天晚上在牛棚里投球，他尝试过休息一周看看休息是否有帮助。他看自己的录像，并与自己投得好时候的录像进行对比。他去看过催眠师和心理学家。他学习冥想并练习它。当朋友建议换穿更宽松的内衣时，他和队友们一起笑了笑。然后，他试了。
Some of these cures focused him more on his mechanics. Some of them tried to take his mind off of his mechanics. None of them worked.
其中一些疗法让他更关注自己的力学动作。其中一些试图转移他对力学动作的注意力。没有一个起作用。
When you see other players go through this, like watching Rick Ankiel on television, is it hard for you to watch?
当你看到其他球员经历这些时，比如在电视上看到里克·安基尔，你看着很难受吗？
Oh, very difficult. In fact, Ankiel was still trying to pitch when I was broadcasting, when they would come into Pittsburgh. And I watched one of his last games. And it was just heartbreaking because I knew what he was going through. And so I don't want to say it was difficult for me, because what I do, I try to do professionally. But it was very, very uncomfortable for me to watch, very sad for me to watch.
噢，非常艰难。事实上，当我在做广播工作时，安基尔还在尝试投球，当他们来到匹兹堡时。我看过他最后一场比赛之一。那简直让人心碎，因为我知道他在经历什么。所以我不想说这对我来说很困难，因为我的工作是尽量专业地去做。但看着那场比赛让我感到非常非常不舒服，非常难过。
You must have said something during the broadcast, though, when you saw him.
不过，当你看到他时，你在广播里一定说了些什么。
I said-- yeah. I said, this is very difficult for me to watch. I'm not enjoying this. The Pirates are benefiting because of what he's going through. But it's not the most comfortable thing for me to watch because it brings back some memories.
我说了……是啊，我说，看着这场景对我来说非常困难。我并不享受这个。海盗队因为他的遭遇而获益。但看着他对我来说并不是最舒服的事情，因为它带回了一些回忆。
Hm. So there's a chapter in your book that's called "They Named a Disease After Me." Is it annoying to have your name attached to this?
嗯。所以你书里有一章叫《他们以我的名字命名了一种疾病》。你的名字和这个挂钩，很烦人吗？
It's not my favorite thing. I'm not crazy about it. But I understand it. Every once in a while, I get a little frustrated and say, you know what? Why don't we talk a little more about the seventh game of the World Series?
这不是我最喜欢的事情。我不太喜欢它。但我理解。每隔一段时间，我会感到有点沮丧，说：你知道吗？我们为什么不谈谈世界大赛第七场比赛呢？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
Come on! I mean, the average major league career is 3.7 years. And I pitched for 10 years and won 100 games. Come on, let's talk about some of that stuff. Let's go! I mean, you're talking about two years out of a charmed life. I lived my dream. I mean, how many people get to do that? So I had a couple of difficult years, very difficult years. But I've been blessed. And I'm not a religious person, but I've been blessed.
拜托！我是说，大联盟职业生涯平均是3.7年。我投了10年球，赢了100场比赛。拜托，我们谈谈那些东西吧。我们开始吧！我是说，你是在谈论我这迷人一生中仅仅两年的时间。我实现了我的梦想。我是说，有多少人能做到这一点？所以我有了几年困难时期，非常困难的几年。但我很受祝福。我不是一个宗教人士，但我确实受过祝福。
Blass says a few years ago he met with a sport psychiatrist named Richard Crowley who taught him a technique. He says it's something to do with trading negative thoughts for positive ones. And decades after he left baseball, he got back on the mound. He now pitches games where former pros and amateurs play together. It is a long way from the majors. But Blass says he got what he wanted-- the pleasure of throwing the ball again. "I had the joy of throwing a baseball since I was eight years old," he says. And he really missed that.
布拉斯说几年前他遇到了一位叫理查德·克劳利（Richard Crowley）的运动心理学家，他教了他一种技术。他说这与用积极的想法交换消极的想法有关。在离开棒球几十年后，他又回到了投手丘上。他现在参加前职业球员和业余爱好者一起打球的比赛。这距离大联盟还有很远的路。但布拉斯说他得到了他想要的——再次投球的乐趣。“从八岁起我就享受投棒球的快乐，”他说。他真的很怀念那种感觉。
Act Two, The Conversation. There's this new podcast out there that's trying to re-imagine and reinvent one of the old radio formats, a format that is barely holding on. You barely hear this format outside of Prairie Home Companion or Bible stations-- radio drama. They're trying to make radio drama that doesn't sound like an antique thing from the 1940s, but feels completely contemporary.
第二幕，对话。有一个新的播客试图重新构想和重新发明一种古老的广播形式，一种几乎快要消失的格式。除了《草原家庭伴侣》（Prairie Home Companion）或宗教电台，你几乎听不到这种格式——广播剧。他们试图制作不听起来像1940年代古董的广播剧，而是感觉完全现代的广播剧。
What I find interesting about this is it's like they took the sound of programs like Radio Lab , or our program, and they use all of the production techniques and tools that go with that, but with actors in a drama. So what you're about to hear is a work of fiction from producer, director Jonathan Mitchell and The Truth .
我发现有趣的是，就像他们采用了《放射实验室》（Radio Lab）或我们节目的声音，使用所有的制作技术和工具，但演员演的是戏剧。所以你即将听到的是制片人兼导演乔纳森·米切尔（Jonathan Mitchell）和《真相》（The Truth）带来的虚构作品。
It was our first date. We had never met.
这是我们的第一次约会。我们以前从未见过面。
Hey, can I get you anything?
嘿，要我给你拿点什么吗？
Uh, me?
呃，我吗？
Yeah.
对。
We'd emailed, but we hadn't even spoken.
我们发过邮件，但甚至没交谈过。
Well, I should wait.
嗯，我应该等一下。
And I was waiting for her. Waiting, and waiting, and waiting.
而我一直在等她。等着，等着，等着。
[IPHONE RINGTONE]
[iPhone铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Ben. It's Erica calling.
嘿，本。我是埃里卡（Erica）。
Hey, Erica! How are you?
嘿，埃里卡！你好吗？
Hi, I'm-- I'm so sorry. I'm running just a little bit late.
嗨，我……我很抱歉。我稍微晚了一点点。
OK, that's OK. That's totally OK. I'm here.
好的，没关系。完全没关系。我在这儿呢。
OK, Tulip's-- you know, Tulip's been sick lately. So I had to-- I finally took her to the vet.
好的，郁金香……你知道的，郁金香（Tulip）最近病了。所以我得……我终于带她去看兽医了。
Oh. Is she OK?
噢。她还好吗？
She is, she is. Thank you.
她还好，她还好。谢谢。
Good. Do you know how long you're going to be?
很好。你知道你要多久才能到吗？
I-- look, I just got out of the subway, and I'm walking down the street, so very soon.
我……听着，我刚出地铁，正在街上走着，所以很快就到了。
All right, great. Do you want me order you a drink so it's ready for when you get here?
好极了。要我先帮你点杯饮料吗，这样你一到就能喝？
Ah, sure.
啊，当然。
What do you want?
你想喝什么？
Do you not want to do this? Because we don't have to do this.
你是不想做这个吗？因为我们不必非得做这个。
Know what, my reception's really bad. I don't think I'm hearing right. So I'm-- just let me run outside real quick. All right, that is better. Can you hear me?
知道吗，我这信号太差了。我觉得我听不太清。所以我……让我跑出去快点。好了，这样好多了。你能听到吗？
Yeah, hi.
是的，嗨。
You know, Erica, I think I see you. Do you see me? I'm right outside the bar. I'm waving.
你知道吗，埃里卡，我想我看到你了。你看到我了吗？我就在酒吧外面。我在挥手呢。
Yes, I see you. I see--
是的，我看到了。我看到……
Hey!
嘿！
Hi.
嗨。
Hi! Um, are you all right?
嗨！呃，你还好吗？
Yeah, I am OK.
是的，我还好。
I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。
You didn't need to say that. That was really unnecessary.
你没必要说那话。那太没必要了。
I'm sorry. I'm not sure what I said. But I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。我不太确定我说了什么。但我很抱歉。
You know, I was-- I was really actually looking forward to this.
你知道，我……我真的很期待这次约会。
What do you mean you were looking forward to this? What are you doing?
你说你很期待这次约会是什么意思？你在做什么？
Forget it.
算了吧。
You're walking the wrong way. Are you still there? Erica, are you joking? What is going on? Erica!
你走错方向了。你还在吗？埃里卡，你在开玩笑吗？发生了什么事？埃里卡！
I mean, I was really confused, and--
我是说，我真的很困惑，然后……
Hello, are you on the phone still? The hell!
喂，你还在通话吗？见鬼！
--I couldn't tell if she was still on, or if she hung up. And I'm looking at my phone. And I see that I had recently downloaded this app that records phone calls. And I looked at it and was like, I gotta listen to that recording.
……我不知道她是否还在，或者她是否挂断了。我看着我的手机。我看到我最近下载了这个记录通话的应用。我看了看它，心想：我得听听那个录音。
Hello.
喂。
Hi, Ben. It's Erica calling.
嘿，本。我是埃里卡。
Started out the same exact way as I had just recalled it. Then, it starts to sound like not me.
开始的方式和我刚才回忆的一模一样。然后，它听起来就不像是我了。
Do you know how long you're gonna be?
你知道你要多久才能到吗？
Uh-- look, I just got out the subway. I'm walking down the street, so very soon.
呃……听着，我刚出地铁。我正在街上走着，所以很快。
OK, great. Do you want me to order you a drink so it's ready for when you get here?
好的，太好了。要我帮你点杯饮料，这样你到的时候就能喝了吗？
Uh, sure.
呃，当然。
What do you want?
你想喝什么？
Do you not want to do this? Because we don't have to do.
你不想做这个了吗？因为我们没必要……
You know what? Um, my reception's really bad. I don't think I'm hearing right.
你知道吗？呃，我这信号太差了。我觉得我听不太清。
It's the exact same words that I believe I had just said. But when I listen to tape, it sounded like not me.
这和我相信我刚才说的话一模一样。但当我听磁带时，听起来不像是我。
That is better.
这样好多了。
But this jerk.
但这混蛋。
Can you hear me?
你能听到吗？
Yeah, hi.
是的，嗨。
You know what, Erica? I think I see you. Do you see me? I'm right outside the bar.
你知道吗，埃里卡？我想我看到你了。你看到我了吗？我就在酒吧外面。
I--
我……
I'm waving.
我在挥手。
Yes, I see you. I see--
是的，我看到了。我看到……
Hey!
嘿！
Hi.
嗨。
I don't know who that was. That wasn't me. I'm not that person.
我不知道那是谁。那不是我。我不是那种人。
You know, I was-- I was really actually looking forward to this.
你知道，我……我真的很期待这次约会。
What do you mean you're looking forward to this? What are you doing?
你说你很期待这次约会是什么意思？你在做什么？
Forget it.
算了吧。
I'm glad she hung up because, god, what would I have said next? I wanted to, like, run after her, and find her, and apologize. But I was like, I should never say another word as long as I live.
我很高兴她挂断了，因为，天哪，接下来我会说什么？我想追过去，找到她，道歉。但我心想：我这辈子再也不要说一句话了。
You tell me right now. Do I sound rude to you? Did that sound rude when I say, "Do I sound rude?"
你现在告诉我。我对你听起来很无礼吗？当我问“我对你听起来很无礼吗？”的时候，听起来很无礼吗？
Honey, you sound confused.
亲爱的，你听起来很困惑。
I am confused!
我是很困惑！
Honey, just call her-- call her and try again.
亲爱的，打给她吧……打给她，再试一次。
No, it's just not like I can pick up the phone and call her unless I know what the hell I'm doing wrong.
不，我不能就这样拿起电话打给她，除非我知道我到底哪里做错了。
Sweetie, it's probably just a misunderstanding.
亲爱的，那可能只是个误会。
Well, could you listen to the tape and tell me if I sound--
嗯，你能听听录音，告诉我我听起来是否……
Oh, Ben, I don't want to do that.
噢，本，我不想那样做。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
Because that's not my-- ah, ah, ah! Stop that! You stop that right-- get down! Get off that!
因为那不是我的……啊，啊，啊！住手！你快停下……下来！从那上面下来！
Mom?
妈？
Shoot.
该死。
It's just one phone call, Mom, and it's really short.
妈，这只是一个电话，而且很短。
No, honey. I am not listening to your discussion with a girl.
不，亲爱的。我不会听你和一个女孩的讨论。
Why? Why not?
为什么？为什么不？
Because that's just creepy.
因为那太令人毛骨悚然了。
Do I sound creepy?
我听起来很令人毛骨悚然吗？
You sound like you sound.
你听起来就像你听起来的那样。
Hi! Hi. Well, here we are, huh? I'm so glad to finally meet you.
嘿！嗨。嗯，我们终于见面了，对吧？我很高兴终于见到你了。
I just was testing out some recordings of myself to hear whether or not it was the device, or the way it was recorded, or something.
我只是在测试一些我自己的录音，看看是设备的问题，还是录制方式的问题，或者别的什么。
Your laugh is contagious.
你的笑声很有感染力。
And then, I would play it back.
然后，我会回放它。
Well, here we are, huh?
嗯，我们终于见面了，对吧？
And it sounded fine.
听起来还不错。
I am so glad to finally meet you.
我很高兴终于见到你了。
I took the recording of the call between me and Erica, and I loaded it in my computer. And I wanted to analyze it. So I divided it up, took my side of the conversation, and cut that out, and separated the two.
我把我和埃里卡通话的录音放进电脑里。我想分析它。所以我把它拆开，取出了我那部分的对话，切掉，把两者分开了。
Hi, Ben. It's Erica calling. Hi, I'm-- I'm so sorry. I'm running just a little bit late.
嘿，本。我是埃里卡。嗨，我……我很抱歉。我稍微晚了一点点。
Categories, subcategories-- I just put all the questions in one file, and then all of her statements in another file, and then--
分类，子分类……我只是把所有问题放在一个文件里，然后把她所有的陈述放在另一个文件里，然后……
Do you now want to do this? Because we don't have to do this.
你不想做这个了吗？因为我们不必非得做这个。
I mean, yeah, she was upset.
我是说，是的，她很心烦。
Yes, I see you! I see-- hi.
是的，我看到了！我看到……嗨。
She was also patient, and--
她也很有耐心，并且……
Yeah, I am OK.
是的，我还好。
--sincere, and genuine, and authentic.
……真诚、纯粹且真实。
You know, I was-- I was really actually looking forward to this.
你知道，我……我真的很期待这次约会。
And I thought, well, what if I put something in there that I know is nice.
我想，那如果我放一些我知道是好的话进去呢。
Well, here we are, huh?
嗯，我们终于见面了，对吧？
Hi!
嘿！
And I'm so glad to finally meet you.
我很高兴终于见到你了。
I was really actually looking forward to this.
我真的很期待这次约会。
Yeah, me too, definitely.
是啊，我也是，绝对。
It sounded great. So, you know, I just for fun kind of expanded on that and--
听起来棒极了。所以，你知道，我只是为了好玩，扩展了一下，然后……
Oh, these are for you.
噢，这是给你的。
You didn't need to--
你没必要……
I know I didn't need to. I think you said these were your favorite, right?
我知道我没必要。我想你说过这些是你最喜欢的，对吧？
Yeah, tulips.
是的，郁金香。
Yep, they're for you.
是的，它们是给你的。
That was really unnecessary.
那太没必要了。
Well, you only get one first date.
嗯，第一次约会只有一次。
Do you want to do this--?
你想要……？
Again?
再一次？
Yeah.
是的。
You want to set up a second date this early in our first date?
你想在第一次约会这么早的时候就安排第二次约会？
Yeah! Very soon.
是的！很快。
Why couldn't it have gone that way?
为什么它不能那样发展呢？
Whoa, whoa!
哇，哇！
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You know, I remember being a lot better at ice skating.
你知道，我记得我溜冰技术好多了。
Do you not want to do this? Because we don't have to do this.
你不想做这个了吗？因为我们不必非得做这个。
You're just saying that because we're both unable to get back up.
你这么说只是因为我们都无法站起来了。
Yeah-- hi.
是的……嗨。
Hi. What do you call that awesome move you were just attempting?
嗨。你把你刚才尝试的那个超酷动作叫什么？
Walking down the street.
在街上走着。
You really sold it with the whole falling hard on your butt thing.
你卖力表现出来的就是那场狠狠摔在屁股上的戏吧。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Are you OK?
你还好吗？
Yeah, I am OK.
是的，我还好。
And the article said that like 90% of the world's oceans are unexplored. You know? And we think we know everything. But most of our knowledge is--
文章说大概90%的世界海洋是未被探索的。你知道吗？我们以为我们什么都知道。但我们大部分的知识是……
--really unnecessary.
……真的没必要。
Right, yeah, exactly! Totally unnecessary! I mean, do you think that there are things that will always remain a mystery?
对，是啊，没错！完全没必要！我是说，你认为会有永远保持神秘的事物吗？
Uh-- I--
呃……我……
What? Say it-- what?
什么？说出来……什么？
I'm so sorry!
我真的很抱歉！
It's OK. I know what the problem is. We're working with a limited supply of words here.
没关系。我知道问题出在哪里了。我们这里词汇储备有限。
I-- I know.
我……我知道。
Let me think. OK, how's your steak. Good?
让我想想。好的，你的牛排怎么样。好吃吗？
Sure?
确定？
Sure? Sure? Sure. I wish you could just say that it was awesome, or succulent, or terrible! Like an old shoe.
确定？确定？确定。我希望你只是说它很棒，或者多汁，或者糟糕！就像一只旧鞋子。
Ben, I'm so sorry--
本，我很抱歉……
No, Erica, you-- you need more words.
不，埃里卡，你……你需要更多的词。
You don't have to do this.
你不必做这个。
Let me just get you some more words.
让我给你找更多的词。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Erica? Hi, it's Ben.
埃里卡？嗨，我是本。
Ben--?
本……？
Yeah, we used to-- well, we almost went out on a date.
是的，我们曾经……嗯，我们差点就去约会了。
Oh, Ben. Yes, hi.
噢，本。是的，嗨。
Hi. How are you?
嗨。你好吗？
I'm fine.
我很好。
Good, me too. I'm just calling because I felt like-- I just wanted to say that I felt bad about how things ended up. And I wanted to apologize, so.
很好，我也是。我打电话只是因为我觉得……我只是想说我很抱歉事情变成了那样。我想道歉，所以。
Oh, god, no. It's-- that's OK.
噢，天哪，不。没关系……没关系的。
Uh, cool. I just-- you know, I made you feel really upset. And I feel bad about that, so I just--
呃，酷。我只是……你知道，我让你感到很心烦。我对那感到很抱歉，所以我就……
Don't-- don't worry about it. I wasn't that upset, so.
别……别担心。我没那么心烦，所以。
Well then, I mean, you just walked away like that. So I just-- you definitely seemed--
好吧，我是说，你就那样走开了。所以我只是……你看起来确实……
Right, right. Well, I-- I walked away-- I was very upset because of earlier that night, my dog, Tulip, died.
对，对。好吧，我……我走开了……我非常心烦，因为那天早些时候，我的狗郁金香死了。
Oh.
噢。
In my arms at the vet.
在我怀里，在兽医那儿。
I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。
So-- yeah, yeah, thank you. Thanks.
所以……是啊，是啊，谢谢。谢谢。
Sorry. But she didn't die that day, though?
抱歉。但她那天没死吧？
What?
什么？
She didn't die that day. That's not-- That's not what happened.
她那天没死。那不是……那不是发生的事。
Yes, she did. She died.
是的，她死了。她死了。
Mm-hm, right. But, well, you just were coming from the vet. And you were just sad that she was sick.
嗯，对。但是，好吧，你当时刚从兽医那回来。你只是因为她病了而难过。
OK, well, I think I remember when my dog died.
好的，好吧，我想我记得我的狗死的时候。
No, that's-- well, it's wrong because-- I mean, I know-- I know what you said.
不，那……嗯，那是错的，因为……我是说，我知道……我知道你说了什么。
Are you kidding me?
你在开玩笑吗？
No. I could play it back to you if you want, but I mean it's--
不。如果你想听，我可以放给你听，但我的意思是它是……
What do you mean you could play it back to me?
你放给我听是什么意思？
Well, I recorded the call because--
嗯，我录下了那个通话，因为……
You recorded our phone call?
你录下了我们的通话？
Yeah, I just accidentally-- it was an accident.
是的，我只是不小心……那是个意外。
Oh my god.
噢，天哪。
I recorded it. And I've listened to it a bunch of times. So I know exactly what you said.
我录下来了。我听了好多次。所以我很清楚你说了什么。
You've listened to it a bunch of times?
你听了好多次？
Yeah. I know.
是的。我知道。
That's super creepy.
这超级令人毛骨悚然。
Well--
嗯……
Wait, are you recording this phone call right now?
等等，你现在在录这个电话吗？
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Oh my god! What is your problem?
噢，天哪！你有什么毛病？
No, I'm not! You're-- what is your problem? Because-- why would you say that your dog is just sick if she's dead, or either that, or you're lying now about your dog?
不，我没录！你……你有什么毛病？因为……如果你的狗死了，你为什么要说她只是病了，或者二选一，你在关于你的狗撒谎？
God, I lied, OK? I lied then. Get over it.
天哪，我撒谎了，行吗？我当时撒谎了。算了吧。
OK, sorry. I'm sorry about your dog, too. I know that's--
好的，抱歉。我也为你的狗感到遗憾。我知道那……
My dog is fine. She's not dead, OK? God.
我的狗很好。她没死，好吗？天哪。
I'm sorry. I don't understand because--
我很抱歉。我不明白，因为……
You want to  know what happened, Ben?
你想知道发生了什么吗，本？
Well, yeah.
嗯，想。
I met someone else. The night before you and I were supposed to go out, I met this great guy and we fell in love because he's awesome. And I showed up to tell you. And then you acted so crazy.
我遇到了别人。在你和我应该去约会的前一天晚上，我遇到了这个很棒的家伙，我们坠入爱河，因为他太棒了。我露面是为了告诉你。然后你的表现太疯狂了。
Yeah, you were like 40 minutes late!
是啊，你迟到了40分钟！
You know what? It was a-- it was a really weird night.
你知道吗？那是个……那是个非常奇怪的夜晚。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I couldn't deal. And I wanted to see Derek.
我应付不了。我想见德里克（Derek）。
Oh.
噢。
OK? And I left.
行吗？我走了。
Wait, so you planned to blow me off?
等等，所以你计划甩了我？
That's what I did, and that's what I did.
我就是这么做的，我就是这么做的。
How do you fall in love with someone in one night?
你怎么会在一个晚上就爱上别人？
I don't-- um. I don't really know what to say.
我不知道……嗯。我真的不知道该说什么。
I just-- wait, oh, my phone's gonna die. Let-- I'm going to-- can I call you right back?
我只是……等等，噢，我的手机要没电了。让……我要……我可以回给你吗？
Actually, don't do it.
其实，别回了。
I'm gonna call you right ba--
我要回……
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, we were talking, and I had to, um--
嘿，我们刚才在聊天，我不得不，嗯……
Yeah, hi.
是的，嗨。
How you doing?
你怎么样？
I'm fine.
我很好。
Good. I just needed to tell you something.
很好。我只是有件事要告诉你。
Sure.
说吧。
It's-- it's over, Erica.
埃里卡，结束了。
Are you kidding me?
你在开玩笑吧？
No.
不。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Hey, come on, now. No, we-- we gave it a shot. You know? But the thing is, you're not real. And real you is right. This is super creepy.
嘿，算了吧。不，我们……我们试过了。你知道吗？但问题是，你不是真实的。真实的你是对的。这超级毛骨悚然。
It's super creepy.
这超级毛骨悚然。
Yeah. What the hell have I been doing? I acted like a jerk, and I don't know. It's been like I'm trying to undo it, or figure it out, or something. And I mean, the reality is I acted like a jerk because at that moment, I was a jerk.
是的。我到底在干什么？我像个混蛋一样，我不知道。就像我试图撤销它，或者弄清楚它，或者什么。我是说，现实是我表现得像个混蛋，因为在那一刻，我就是个混蛋。
Don't-- don't worry about it. I wasn't that upset, so.
别……别担心。我没那么心烦，所以。
Well, that's good.
好吧，那很好。
Yeah.
是啊。
Goodbye, Erica. Are you still there?
再见，埃里卡。你还在那儿吗？
No.
不在。
Yeah, me neither.
是的，我也不在。
Those actors, Ed Herbstman and Tami Sagher, with Libby George as the mom and Christian Paluck very briefly as the bartender. This story was produced and directed by Jonathan Mitchell, who also did the music. The story was written by Jonathan Mitchell, Ed Herbstman, and Melanie Hoops. If you liked what you just heard, they're doing one like this every two weeks on their podcast that's called The Truth . Their website, thetruthapm.com, or look for The Truth podcast at the iTunes store.
那些演员，埃德·赫布斯特曼（Ed Herbstman）和塔米·萨格（Tami Sagher），还有扮演妈妈的利比·乔治（Libby George）和短暂客串酒保的克里斯蒂安·帕卢克（Christian Paluck）。这个故事由乔纳森·米切尔制作和导演，他也制作了音乐。这个故事由乔纳森·米切尔、埃德·赫布斯特曼和梅兰妮·胡普斯（Melanie Hoops）编写。如果你喜欢刚才听到的，他们每两周会在他们的播客《真相》（The Truth）上制作一个这样的节目。他们的网站是thetruthapm.com，或者在iTunes商店里搜索《真相》播客。
Coming up, a man who does not approve of homosexuality whose biggest problem is he is homosexual. Stories of being your own worst enemy continue in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个不赞成同性恋却最大的问题是自己也是同性恋的人。关于成为自身最大敌人的故事将在芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台节目继续的一分钟后继续播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Own Worst Enemy, stories of people who thwart themselves in ways that they do not seem to be able to control.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于这个主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目主题是“自身最大敌人”，讲述人们以自己似乎无法控制的方式挫败自己的故事。
We have arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Just As I Am. This last story is about somebody who is at war with himself. He's a gay man, a Christian, who did not want to be gay or act on his feelings for men. And he didn't just want to suppress this impulse in himself. He wasn't just his own worst enemy. He tried to get other gay men and women to suppress that part of themselves as well. But then, through a series of actions that can only be described as very Christian, this man changed. Jonathan Menjivar tells what happened.
我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，就如我所是（Just As I Am）。最后一个故事是关于一个与自己处于战争状态的人。他是一个同性恋，一个基督徒，他不希望自己是同性恋，也不想顺从对男人的感觉。他不仅仅是想压抑自己内心的这种冲动。他不只是自己的最大敌人。他还试图让其他同性恋男女也压抑自己那部分。但后来，通过一系列只能被描述为非常基督徒的行为，这个人改变了。乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）讲述了发生的事情。
The guy's name was John Smid, and he ran an organization called Love in Action, one of those Christian places that claims they can cure people of their homosexuality. Make them not exactly straight, but ex-gay. It was in Memphis, Tennessee. And at the time, it was the oldest and most prominent ex-gay ministry in the world. One former client told me it was considered the Cadillac of ex-gay programs. The rules were harsh, the level of shame, intense. Former clients have spent years in therapy unwinding what happened to them at Love in Action. And John Smid was the head of that group for more than two decades.
那个家伙叫约翰·斯米德（John Smid），他经营着一个叫“生活中的爱”（Love in Action）的组织，这是那种声称能治愈同性恋的基督教机构之一。不是让他们变得完全异性恋，而是“前同性恋”。它位于田纳西州的孟菲斯。在当时，它是世界上最古老、最著名的前同性恋事工。一位前客户告诉我，它被认为是前同性恋项目的“凯迪拉克”。规则很严苛，羞耻感程度很高。前客户们花了多年时间在心理治疗中化解他们在“生活中的爱”经历的一切。约翰·斯米德担任那个小组的负责人超过二十年。
As for his own homosexuality, John never tried to hide it. It was part of his testimony he'd give at church and ex-gay events. John was married at 19. And then, after having two kids, he realized he was gay. He got divorced, had a couple gay relationships. John says he was also pretty promiscuous. And then, in his late 20s, he found god and stopped living as a gay man. This is John giving that testimony on an old Christian TV segment. John says he was in this little, country church in Iowa.
至于他自己的同性恋，约翰从没试图隐瞒。这是他在教堂和前同性恋活动中提供的见证的一部分。约翰19岁时结婚。然后，在有了两个孩子后，他意识到自己是同性恋。他离婚了，有过几次同性恋关系。约翰说他也相当滥交。然后，在他快30岁时，他找到了上帝，停止了作为同性恋的生活。这是约翰在一段老基督教电视节目中提供的见证。约翰说他在爱荷华州的一个小乡村教堂里。
I just remember sitting in the pew. And this voice spoke into my brain, "John," called my name, "you don't have to live like this anymore." It was just that point when God spoke, and I gained permission to ask for freedom. And I started praying every day. I just kept saying every day, God, get me out of this. Get me out of this. I'm miserable. God, get me out of this. And eventually, I got to the point where I left the partners and the relationships. And that was the end of my homosexuality.
我只记得坐在长椅上。一个声音在我的脑海中响起，“约翰，”叫着我的名字，“你不必再这样生活了。”就在上帝说话的那一刻，我获得了寻求自由的许可。我开始每天祈祷。我只是每天不停地说：上帝，让我脱离这个。让我脱离这个。我很痛苦。上帝，让我脱离这个。最终，我达到了那种离开伙伴和关系的程度。这就是我同性恋生活的终结。
John made a new life for himself, dated women, and then he married one, his second wife. he soon got a job encouraging other gay men to live the way he was. And then, almost 20 years after John joined Love in Action, he decided to expand their mission.
约翰为自己开启了新生活，和女性约会，然后嫁给了一个女人，他的第二任妻子。他很快找到了一份鼓励其他同性恋者过他那种生活的工作。然后，在约翰加入“生活中的爱”近20年后，他决定扩大他们的使命。
Love in Action had always been for adults. But John says he was seeing a dramatic increase in teens coming. Their parents were calling Love in Action more and more. So they started a new program specifically for teenagers. At the time, Love in Action had just bought a new building. It was step up for them. Then, John came to work. It was the first day of the new teen program.
“生活中的爱”一直都是针对成人的。但约翰说他看到青少年来访的数量激增。他们的父母越来越多地打电话给“生活中的爱”。所以他们开始了一个专门针对青少年的新项目。当时，“生活中的爱”刚刚买了一栋新大楼。这对他们来说是向前迈出了一步。然后，约翰去上班。那是青少年新项目的第一天。
It was 8:30, June 6, 2005, sitting in my office. And one of my staff members came in and said, a client just came and told us that there's a big protest outside.
那是2005年6月6日早上8:30，坐在我的办公室里。我的一个员工走进来，说一位客户刚来告诉我们外面有个大规模抗议活动。
It's OK to be gay!
同性恋没问题！
And then, what did you do?
然后，你做了什么？
Freaked out.
吓坏了。
It's OK to be gay!
同性恋没问题！
I didn't know what to do. I felt incredibly exposed. It was the first day in our building. We had just moved in.
我不知道该怎么办。我感到极其脆弱。那是我们搬进这栋大楼的第一天。我们刚搬进来。
Homosexuality is not a sin. Homosexuality is not an addiction!
同性恋不是罪。同性恋不是成瘾！
The new program for teens was called Refuge, and it's why the protesters were there. Love in Action was a voluntary program. But Refuge was different, at least according to a 16-year-old kid named Zach Stark. A week earlier, Zach had posted on his MySpace page saying that he had come out and his parents didn't take it well. So they were forcing him to go to Refuge. "They tell me that there is something psychologically wrong with me," Zach wrote. "I'm a big screw up to them who isn't on the path God wants me to be on."
这个针对青少年的新项目叫“避难所”（Refuge），这就是抗议者在那里的原因。“生活中的爱”是一个自愿项目。但“避难所”不同，至少根据一个叫扎克·斯塔克（Zach Stark）的16岁孩子所说。一周前，扎克在MySpace页面上发帖称他已经出柜，但他父母对此反应不佳。所以他们强迫他去“避难所”。“他们告诉我我在心理上有什么问题，”扎克写道。“在他们眼中我是一个很大的失败者，没有走在上帝希望我走的道路上。”
It was impossible not to want to help him.
不去想帮助他是不可能的。
This is Morgan Jon Fox. He's a Memphis filmmaker, and he was pretty much the ringleader of the protests. He'd read Zach's blog and pulled together other activists and a bunch of Zach's friends from high school. Morgan is gay himself, and he filmed a lot of the protest. He and all the other protesters couldn't believe what they were reading on Zach's blog. To them, it seemed like a cry for help.
这是摩根·琼·福克斯（Morgan Jon Fox）。他是一位孟菲斯电影制作人，基本上是抗议活动的领袖。他读了扎克的博客，把其他活动家和扎克的一群高中朋友召集在一起。摩根自己也是同性恋，他拍摄了大量抗议活动。他和所有其他抗议者都不敢相信他们在扎克的博客上读到的东西。对他们来说，这看起来像是一个求救信号。
And then, he goes on to explain that he ran away for a day, and now he's come back. And he's writing these blog entries in the middle of the night. And that if he gets caught, you know, it could be very bad. And then, he went on to post the rules of this organization.
然后，他继续解释说他跑掉了一天，现在又回来了。他在深夜写这些博客条目。如果被抓住，你知道，这可能会非常糟糕。然后，他继续发布了这个组织的规则。
The kids in Love in Action's teen program went home to their parents every night. But they had to adhere to the rules no matter where they were. There was no hugging or physical contact allowed, though brief handshakes or an affirmative hand on a shoulder were OK. Any, quote, "temptations, fantasies, or dreams" were supposed to be confessed to a staff member. Men were supposed to dress like men, and women like women. And for some reason, no one was allowed to wear anything by Abercrombie & Fitch or Calvin Klein.
“生活中的爱”青少年项目的孩子们每天回家见父母。但无论他们在哪里，都必须遵守规则。不允许任何拥抱或身体接触，尽管短暂握手或在肩膀上给予肯定的拍打是可以的。任何所谓的“诱惑、幻想或梦想”都应该向工作人员坦白。男人应该像男人一样着装，女人应该像女人一样。而且由于某种原因，不允许任何人穿Abercrombie & Fitch或Calvin Klein的任何东西。
The protests clearly had two intended targets-- Zach, who they were there to support, and John Smid, the guy they were shouting at through their bull horns. Morgan was there for weeks, making every attempt to get through to John.
抗议活动显然有两个预定的目标——扎克（他们去支持的人），和约翰·斯米德（他们通过扩音器叫喊的人）。摩根在那里待了几个星期，竭尽全力想接触约翰。
We knew that John Smid was the head of the organization. And essentially, he was our enemy in this situation.
我们知道约翰·斯米德是该组织的负责人。从本质上讲，他是我们这种情况下的敌人。
Why they can't question your policies!
为什么他们不能质疑你们的政策！
Why, John Smid?
为什么，约翰·斯米德？
He never came and addressed us. There was one day, he was driving. And he stopped for one moment. And we made sure at that very moment we saw him, because it was kind of like this-- man, I don't know. It's like seeing Sasquatch. You know, we never got to see him. And then, so when we would actually see him in person, it was like, OK, this is our moment. We gotta do something right, or we've got to prove something.
他从未出来对我们发表讲话。有一天，他正在开车。他停了一瞬间。我们在那一刻确保看到了他，因为那就像……天哪，我不知道。就像看到大脚怪一样。你知道，我们从来没能见到他。所以当我们真正亲眼见到他时，就像是：好的，这是我们的时刻。我们要把事情做对，或者我们必须证明点什么。
The protests at Love in Action became a national news story. They got picked up by CNN, the New York Times , and Good Morning America . Eight weeks later when it was all over and Zach Stark had finished the program, Morgan wanted to interview John Smid for the documentary he'd started working on about the protests. John says he didn't want anything to do with Morgan.
“生活中的爱”的抗议活动成为了全国新闻事件。它们被CNN、《纽约时报》和《早安美国》报道。八周后，当一切结束，扎克·斯塔克完成了项目，摩根想采访约翰·斯米德，为了他开始制作的关于抗议活动的纪录片。约翰说他不想和摩根有任何关系。
Of course, I understood he had this organization called Queer Action Coalition. And it was just this horribly negative thing that I just don't want anything to do with. and he called and wanted to meet with me. And I said, OK, how do I set up the safeguards? Because you've got to be careful when these gay activists come around. You know, they're going to twist your words. And somehow, they've got an alternative agenda. And they just want to use your words negatively. So I asked one of my staff members to come in and meet with me with him because I didn't want to be him alone because I thought, certainly I need some kind of accountability here.
当然，我知道他有一个叫“酷儿行动联盟”（Queer Action Coalition）的组织。那简直是一个极其负面的东西，我根本不想和它有任何牵扯。他打电话来想要见我。我说：好的，我该如何设置保障措施？因为你必须小心那些同性恋激进分子出现在周围。你知道，他们会歪曲你的话。不知何故，他们有一个替代议程。他们只想消极地利用你的话。所以我请我的一名员工和我一起见他，因为我不想单独见他，因为我想：我肯定需要某种问责制。
And so I walk into his office. The meeting is at Love in Action headquarters. I walk in. And he sits down behind this big desk. And one of his staff members sits down beside him. And I sit across from this big table. And the night before, I had really thought about things I would say, and having this opportunity, and possibly I would debate him. You know, I wanted to have an eloquent argument. I had like a six page document that I had prepared and studied, hoping that those were points that I would hit.
于是我走进他的办公室。会议在“生活中的爱”总部举行。我走进去。他坐在那张大办公桌后面。他的一名员工坐在他旁边。我坐在那张大桌子对面。前一天晚上，我真的思考过我要说的话，有这个机会，而且我也可能和他辩论。你知道，我想要一个雄辩的论点。我有一份我准备和研究了六页的文件，希望能成为我击中的点。
But I sit across the table from him. And he's like, well? And I'm like, yeah? And then, literally like 10 seconds of silence. I'm sitting there. No one is saying anything. And I'm just like, oh my god. And the last thing that was crossing my mind at that moment was to debate or start arguing with him. And so I just started telling him my story.
但我坐在他对面。他像是：那么？我像是：是啊？然后，真的有大概10秒钟的沉默。我坐在那里。没人说话。我心想：噢，天哪。那一刻在我脑海中闪过的最后一件事就是辩论或开始和他争吵。所以我只是开始告诉他我的故事。
I just started telling him about my childhood, when I came out, all the things that I faced, the pain that I felt of not feeling necessarily accepted by peers or family, and about that process of going through all of that, but then being in a relationship, and being out, and feeling loved, and feeling a part of a community here in Memphis, and how much healthier I felt. And then, went on to explain, that's why I protested your organization all of these past few weeks.
我只是开始告诉他我的童年，我出柜的时候，我面对的所有事情，我不被同龄人或家庭接受的痛苦，以及经历这一切的过程，然后是在一段关系中，出柜，感到被爱，感到在孟菲斯这里是社区的一部分，以及我感到多么健康。然后，继续解释这就是为什么我在过去几周抗议你们组织的原因。
And I thought, wait a minute. This is not what I expected. This guy seems to be vulnerable, and honest, and humble. And it's like, this isn't-- I don't hate this guy. How could I hate him? He just came in my office, and treated me with respect, and was honest himself. And he seemed open, and I didn't know what to do with it.
我心想：等等。这不是我预期的。这家伙看起来很脆弱，诚实，谦逊。这就像……我不恨这家伙。我怎么可能恨他？他刚才走进我的办公室，用尊重对待我，自己也很诚实。他看起来很开放，我不知道该怎么办。
They talked for half an hour. And then, Morgan asked John if he'd agree to an interview. John turned him down. For a year after that meeting, there was a kind of ceasefire. John and Morgan didn't talk to each other at all. Then, Morgan and some of the other protesters attended an open meeting at Love in Action. Morgan says they were just trying to keep an eye on them, see what Love in Action were up to.
他们交谈了半小时。然后，摩根问约翰是否同意接受采访。约翰拒绝了他。那次会议后有一年时间，有一种停火。约翰和摩根根本没有交谈。然后，摩根和其他一些抗议者参加了“生活中的爱”的一次公开会议。摩根说他们只是想盯着他们，看看“生活中的爱”在搞什么。
And it was funny because the thing that John talked about at that open meeting was this idea of how we respond to our parents, or how we kind of communicate with them, and deal with the wounds that might be there. It was interesting because at the time, I wasn't that close with my father. And surprisingly, I'm sitting there listening to him say this stuff, and something just clicks in my head that I had been kind of attempting to relate to my father for a long time on my terms only, and not looking at him as a person with the full emotions and issues that he maybe is dealing with.
很有趣，因为约翰在那次公开会议上谈论的事情是关于我们如何回应父母，或者我们如何与他们沟通，并处理可能存在的伤口。这很有趣，因为当时我和我父亲不太亲近。出人意料的是，我坐在那里听他说这些东西，我脑子里突然闪过一个念头：我一直试图只按我的方式与父亲联系，而不是把他看作一个有着完整情感和问题、可能正在处理的人。
And so that was the building blocks towards me becoming closer with my father and mending that relationship. And so that's something that I was extremely grateful for. And so I followed up that meeting in sending John an email, and was like, hey, look, I still totally disagree with everything you're doing. However, I just want to let you know that it's pretty cool that I learned something from your meeting. So just wanted to say thanks, and I appreciate that part of it, even though the rest of it needs to go.
所以那是通向我与父亲变得更亲近、修复那段关系的积木。所以我对此感到非常感激。所以我在那次会议后给约翰发了一封电子邮件，像是：嘿，看，我仍然完全不同意你正在做的一切。然而，我只是想让你知道，我从你的会议中学到点东西真是太酷了。所以只是想说谢谢，我很欣赏那部分，尽管剩下的部分需要滚蛋。
And so I'm thinking, OK, this doesn't match again. My favorite enemy protester is actually complementing me. And he's actually saying that I've had a positive impact. And that kind of blew me away. And so I emailed him back. And I said, Morgan, you know, I would really like to talk with you personally. We should go out and have coffee if you'd like to do that because I've got some things I want to share with you.
于是我心想：好的，这又不匹配了。我最喜欢的敌对抗议者实际上在恭维我。而且他实际上在说我产生了积极的影响。这让我大吃一惊。所以我回信说：摩根，你知道，我真的很想和你个人谈谈。如果你愿意，我们应该出去喝杯咖啡，因为我有一些事情想和你分享。
Morgan and John agreed to meet at a Starbucks. Morgan says the coffee lasted three hours.
摩根和约翰同意在星巴克见面。摩根说咖啡喝了三个小时。
In these three hours, what are you guys talking about?
在这三个小时里，你们在聊什么？
I mean, literally we're talking about what's been going on. He's asking me questions about, oh, so you're a filmmaker? I looked you up on the internet a little bit. You know, that kind of stuff. And so I'm talking about my films. Basically, we talk about anything but the issues, which is fascinating. I mean, we're literally talking about my job at this coffee shop.
我是说，我们真的是在聊一直在发生的事情。他问我关于：噢，所以你是电影制作人？我在互联网上稍微查了你一下。你知道，那种东西。所以我谈论我的电影。基本上，我们谈论除了问题之外的任何事情，这很有趣。我是说，我们真的是在聊我在咖啡店的工作。
Yeah, I was going to say it's almost like an awkward first date.
是啊，我正想说，这几乎就像一次尴尬的第一次约会。
[LAUGHS] That's awkward.
[笑声] 那很尴尬。
And not that there's something romantic going on. But are you concerned at any point to that he actually has a crush on you?
并不是说发生了什么浪漫的事。但你在任何时候担心过他真的暗恋你吗？
I was never concerned about him having a crush on me. I can't say a lot of my friends or my significant other wasn't concerned about that. I mean, certainly that was a joke by a lot of people. Like, oh, he's just trying to hook up with you.
我从没担心过他会暗恋我。我不能说我的很多朋友或我的伴侣对此不担心。我是说，当然那是很多人的一个笑话。像是：噢，他只是在试图和你搞上。
Oh, yeah. I had a couple of friends ask me, are you having an affair with Morgan? People were concerned about us meeting. You know, you shouldn't meet with Morgan alone because you could be tempted. I don't meet with single women or with married women by myself, so you shouldn't meet with a gay man by yourself. You know, is that going to be a problem for you? And I'm thinking, no. Sorry, Morgan, I have not had any romantic inclinations towards Morgan. [LAUGHTER]
噢，是啊。我有几个朋友问我：你在和摩根有外遇吗？人们很担心我们见面。你知道，你不应该独自见摩根，因为你可能会受到诱惑。我从不单独见单身女性或已婚女性，所以你不应该独自见一个同性恋男人。你知道，这会对你有问题吗？我心想：不。抱歉，摩根，我没有对摩根有过任何浪漫倾向。[笑声]
The Fox-Smid Summits continued. But the Refuge program for teens didn't. John shut it down. And over coffee, he told Morgan that Refuge was a bad idea. Morgan says it was the first time he'd heard John admit that he had done anything wrong at Love in Action. It wasn't exactly a change of heart, though. John still believed he could provide ex-gay services to teens. Refuge, he thought, just turned out to be the wrong way to do it. But as time went on, Morgan felt that something significant was starting to shift in John.
福克斯-斯米德峰会继续进行。但针对青少年的“避难所”项目没有。约翰关闭了它。在喝咖啡时，他告诉摩根，“避难所”是个坏主意。摩根说这是他第一次听到约翰承认他在“生活中的爱”做过任何错误的事。但这并不完全是改过自新。约翰仍然相信他可以为青少年提供“前同性恋”服务。“避难所”，他认为，只是被证明是错误的方法。但随着时间流逝，摩根感觉到约翰身上开始有一些重要的东西在转变。
He would ask questions to me. I mean, he was being more willing to hear feedback, and would specifically ask, well, what did you think about this? Or what was it about this? Or he would sort of--
他会问我问题。我是说，他更愿意听取反馈，并会具体问：好吧，你对此怎么想？或者关于这个是什么？或者他会某种程度上……
Like using you as a focus group to see how Love in Action was working?
就像把你当作焦点小组来看看“生活中的爱”是如何运作的？
Yeah, yeah. I mean, I think he even joked at some point about-- he had said something on the news about, "Well, you know, it's just like having to eat your peas. Sometimes, you have to do things you don't want to do," in response to these kids needing to go into Refuge. And I was like, John, are you kidding me? Like, having to eat your peas? And he laughed and was like, what? That didn't work?
是啊，是啊。我是说，我想他甚至在某一点开过玩笑说……他在新闻上说过一些东西：嗯，你知道，这就像不得不吃你的豌豆。有时，你不得不做你不想做的事情，以回应这些孩子需要进入“避难所”。我像是：约翰，你在开玩笑吗？像是不得不吃你的豌豆？他笑了笑说：什么？那不起作用？
I mean, tell me, seriously, if that didn't work. I'm like, [SCOFFS]. But it's just like, are you serious? So definitely, things became-- though we weren't debating the issues, it became certainly more comfortable for me. I felt more comfortable to straight up say, like, come on, are you serious about this? Can you actually believe this? And he was listening.
我是说，严肃地告诉我，如果那不起作用的话。我像是[嗤之以鼻]。但这就像，你是认真的吗？所以事情绝对变得……尽管我们没有辩论这些问题，但对我来说肯定变得更舒服了。我感到更舒服地直说，像是：拜托，你是认真的吗？你真的能相信这个？他在听。
What happened between John and Morgan is the thing that almost never happens between people on opposite sides of a political issue. They sat down, and talked, and really listened to each other. Essentially, Morgan did a very Christian thing. At that first meeting, he turned the other cheek. John saw that, and did the same. And it had an effect. John says that Morgan was the first gay person he met who wasn't in conflict over his sexuality. Morgan seemed normal and healthy. And it surprised John.
约翰和摩根之间发生的事情是几乎从未在政治问题对立面的人之间发生过的事情。他们坐下来，交谈，并真正倾听彼此。从本质上讲，摩根做了一件非常基督徒的事情。在第一次会议上，他转过了另一半脸。约翰看到了，并做了同样的事。这产生了效果。约翰说摩根是他遇到的第一个不因性取向而感到冲突的同性恋者。摩根看起来很正常和健康。这让约翰感到惊讶。
In March, 2008, John quietly resigned from Love in Action. It would be really satisfying if I could tell you that all that listening, all the sitting down over coffee with Morgan snapped John out of the ex-gay stupor he'd been in for more than two decades. But that's not true. John told me when he left Love in Action, he hadn't actually changed his belief at all. He was still ex-gay, still believed that being gay was a sin.
2008年3月，约翰安静地辞去了“生活中的爱”的职务。如果我能告诉你所有这些倾听、所有与摩根一起喝咖啡让他脱离了他陷入二十多年的“前同性恋”昏迷状态，那会非常令人满足。但这不属实。约翰告诉我他离开“生活中的爱”时，他的信念其实一点都没变。他仍然是“前同性恋”，仍然相信同性恋是罪。
Then, last year, John posted this stunning admission on the website of a new ministry he'd started. He said that he'd seen dramatic changes happen in people's lives when they walk through the transformation process with Jesus. But he wrote, quote, "The transformation for the vast majority of homosexuals will not include a change of sexual orientation. Actually, I've never met a man who experienced a change from homosexual to heterosexual." That statement coming from John made news. Here's John with Chris Matthews on Hardball last fall.
然后，去年，约翰在他开始的一个新事工网站上发布了这条惊人的告白。他说他看到当人们与耶稣一起走过转化过程时，人们的生活发生了巨大的变化。但他写道，引用：“绝大多数同性恋者的转化将不包括性取向的改变。事实上，我从未见过一个经历从同性恋转变为异性恋的人。”那句来自约翰的话上了新闻。这是去年秋天约翰在《硬球》（Hardball）节目上与克里斯·马修斯（Chris Matthews）的对话。
John, I guess the question a lot of people, gay and straight, will ask you is what brought you to go public with this pretty important observation since you've been experienced in this world that no one's ever gone through a successful, if you will, or conversion of any kind from gay to straight?
约翰，我想很多人，同性恋和异性恋，会问你的是什么让你公开了这个相当重要的观察结果，因为你在那个世界里有经验，没有人经历过成功的，如果你愿意，或者是从同性恋到异性恋的任何形式的转变？
I think really one of the most significant things, Chris, is that within the gay community, there is--
我想实际上最重要的事情之一是，克里斯，在同性恋社区内，有……
I want to make sure this is clear. John now says God embraces homosexuality, that God loves gays and lesbians, and He sees nothing wrong with their actions. He now fully supports faithful, same-sex commitments. And he started a ministry that reaches out to gay people. But the new John Smid isn't exactly a crusader for the gay movement. He's still learning to navigate who  he is. And whatever transformation he's going through, it's still incomplete. He's working it out in public. And it's clumsy.
我想确保这一点很清楚。约翰现在说上帝拥抱同性恋，上帝爱同性恋者，他认为他们的行为没问题。他现在完全支持忠诚的同性承诺。他开始了一个接触同性恋者的事工。但现在的约翰·斯米德并不完全是同性恋运动的十字军战士。他仍在学习导航他是谁。无论他正在经历什么转变，它仍然是不完整的。他正在公众场合解决这个问题。而且很笨拙。
There've been times on his blog when he's used the word "perversion" while talking about homosexuality. He talks about promiscuity like it's something that gay men just can't avoid without help from God. The things he says now can still be so hurtful and confusing that a former client told me he wishes John would just lay low for a few years until he figures out what he wants to say. Morgan eventually got the interview he was looking for. He and John sat down and talked on camera. And now, they're doing Q&As together, talking to audiences about the documentary Morgan made.
在他的博客上曾经有几次，他在谈论同性恋时使用了“反常”这个词。他谈论滥交就像这是同性恋男人在没有上帝帮助下无法避免的事情一样。他现在说的话仍然可能非常伤人和令人困惑，以至于一位前客户告诉我，他希望约翰能沉寂几年，直到他弄清楚他想说什么。摩根最终得到了他想要的采访。他和约翰坐下来在镜头前交谈。现在，他们一起做问答，和观众谈论摩根制作的纪录片。
Recently, John made probably his biggest shift. He started calling himself gay. Not ex-gay, not ex-ex-gay, just gay. John and his wife are still married. It's obviously confusing for the two of them. But this is the uncomfortable place John Smid has lived in his whole life. When he was in his first marriage in his late teens, he struggled because he was gay. Then, he came out and he struggled with that, so he became ex-gay.
最近，约翰做了他可能最大的转变。他开始称自己为“同性恋”。不是“前同性恋”，不是“前前同性恋”，只是同性恋。约翰和他的妻子仍然结婚。这对他们俩来说显然很困惑。但这就是约翰·斯米德一生中居住的那个不舒服的地方。当他在青少年后期第一次婚姻中时，他挣扎是因为他是同性恋。然后，他出柜了，他对此挣扎，所以他成了“前同性恋”。
We'd all like to believe that, as we get older, we know ourselves better and things get easier. But it doesn't always work out that way. John says now, he's kind of back to where he was in his early 20s-- gay and out, just a lot older this time. He's still really conflicted about what that means.
我们都愿意相信，随着我们年龄增长，我们更了解自己，事情会变得更容易。但情况并不总是那样。约翰说现在，他有点回到他20出头时的状态了——同性恋并出柜，只是这次老多了。他仍然对他意味着什么感到非常矛盾。
Jonathan Menjivar is one of the producers of our program. More information about the documentary that Morgan Jon Fox made is at loveinactionmovie.com.
乔纳森·门吉瓦是我们节目的制作人之一。关于摩根·琼·福克斯制作的纪录片的更多信息在loveinactionmovie.com。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
Thanks to Steve Blass's co-author, Erik Sherman. Their book goes on sale May 1. Thanks for help with our radio drama to Peter Clowning, Carrie Helmen, Chris Bannon, and WNYC. Rick Wolff, who you heard in Act One, does a radio show about sports parenting on New York's WFAN. He can be found on askcoachwolff.com. Major League Baseball footage today was used with permission of Major League Baseball Properties, Inc.
感谢史蒂夫·布拉斯的共同作者埃里克·谢尔曼（Erik Sherman）。他们的书将于5月1日开售。感谢彼得·克劳宁（Peter Clowning）、凯莉·海尔曼（Carrie Helmen）、克里斯·班农（Chris Bannon）和WNYC对我们广播剧的帮助。你在第一幕听到的里克·沃尔夫在纽约的WFAN做关于运动教养的广播节目。他可以在askcoachwolff.com找到。今天的美国职业棒球大联盟录像是在美国职业棒球大联盟资产公司的许可下使用的。
Our website, where right now you can enter our contest to win a signed poster for our May 10 cinema event-- basically, we're going to be doing our show on stage with Mike Birbiglia, David Rakoff, Glenn Washington, and others and beaming it into movie theaters everywhere. Find a theater near you and get tickets before they sell out. You can do all that at thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who has totally figured out what we're up to here at the end of the program when we quote him.
我们的网站，现在你可以进入我们的竞赛，赢得我们5月10日电影活动的签名海报——基本上，我们将和迈克·比比利亚（Mike Birbiglia）、大卫·拉考夫（David Rakoff）、格伦·华盛顿（Glenn Washington）等人一起在舞台上表演我们的节目，并将其照射到各地的电影院。在你附近的电影院找到它，在它们售罄之前买票。你可以做所有这些在thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他在节目结束时我们引用他的时候，完全弄清楚了我们在做什么。
You've got to be careful when these gay activists come around, you know. They're going to twist your words. And somehow, they've got an alternative agenda.
你必须小心那些同性恋激进分子出现在周围，你知道。他们会歪曲你的话。不知何故，他们有一个替代议程。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。